قبل حوالي 12 عاما ومنذ اليوم الاول
للازمه في اليمن كانت السعوديه مصدرا
لمبادره الحل سعت في غير ما مره للحفاظ
على هذا البلد موحدا ومستقرا
شكلت الرياض مركزا لاطلاق عديد المبادرات
لجمع شمل اليمنيين لصالح استقرار المنطقه
ورفع المعاناه الانسانيه عن الشعب اليماني
واشنطن سبق واكدت عبر وزير خارجيتها ان
السعوديه اظهرت رغبتها في الوصول الى
اتفاق سلام باليمن
السعوديه اظهرت من خلال افعالها رغبتها في
الوصول الى اتفاق سلام في اليمن وهو امر
ايجابي للغايه
من واشنطن الى باريس استمرت الاشادات
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون من جهته
رحب العام الماضي بجهود السعوديه ودعمها
للهدنه
نشيد بالجهود السعوديه للتوصل الى حل
سياسي شامل في اليمن
من جهتها دعمت دوله الامارات جهود
السعوديه لتحقيق حل سياسي للحرب في اليمن
لاحلال السلام ووضع حد دائم للاعمال
العدائيه بين جميع الاطراف اليمنيه
المختلفه فالرياض وحدت المكونات اليمنيه
في المجلس الرئاسي واستطاعت انهاء
الخلافات التي عطلت عمل المجلس خلال
الاشهر الماضيه التواصل او الاتصال بين
الشقه المركزيه والحوثيين المملكه لم تغلق
بابها مطلقا طوال سنوات الحرب كانت دائما
المملكه يعني اي باب ينفتح في هذا المجال
سواء بشقه السياسي او بشقه الامنيين كان
دائما يظل الباب مفتوح وكان الرساله
الرئيسيه نحن
باي فرصه ستتيح لنا
ان نجمع اليمنيين ان نقدم اي محفزات
الجانب الحوثي حتى ياتي الى الطاوله سنقوم
بهذا الامر هي اذا شعله امل جديده او
قدتها الرياض بعد محاولات عديده لانهاء
حاله الاستقرار في هذا البلد العربي سيرا
في طريق السلام بلال البشتين العربي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات